[Music]
this truck when I where does he live
we forgot to lock the perp in again the
Chiefs gonna have our badges for this
one I won't tell if you don't
[Music]
what about spring-trap back at the
office what into the street look you
guys focus on getting inside
I'll handle spring-trap
okay buddy let's keep them distracted
[Music]
there you are
here's the truth on the back of my going
man
one mistakes all it takes in this maple
bad no wonder no one's there
no one's ever
[Music]
I need a star
guys and fur back sneaking down the hall
someone's day
would say
[Music]
just focus
something's breathing out beyond the
door hey it's me I swear we've met
before I don't care no one's
guys
[Music]
Oh
yeah
that's not good no no no come on come on
maybe we should just calm down and shut
up there okay just don't come any closer
Oh Matt is stuffing and we're skin like
a suit well now he's just being
ridiculous
[Music]
[Applause]
that's Freddy fazbear he holds a special
place in the hearts of children so you
should show him a little respect you've
a nice shift are you with them no I'm
the Ober driver for a bunch of puppets
what do you want there's a killer
animatronic on the low side freddy
fazbears we'd go to the police but they
probably think we're crazy
sound familiar okay wait hang on a
second even if I was to believe that you
talking robots didn't want to kill me
and even if I was willing to go back to
Freddy fazbear's which I'm not what do I
get out of this psychological damage a
horrible gruesome death 25 years to life
with a cellmate named Buffalo frickin
Bell I don't know proving you didn't lie
to the police would be pretty cool
[Music]
fine
don't touch me freddy's opens in a few
hours we should lay low until everyone
leaves for the night who isolations are
some awesome tunes
[Music]
oh hey guys thanks so much for watching
if you enjoyed this video if there's
actually another night and many previous
nights to watch all the links are in the
description below and annotations all
around my face Thank You random
encounters Thank You Nate wants to
battle thank you everyone who's behind
the scenes as well thank you for
watching I'll be here relaxing
[Music]
you